LIV: Welcome, everybody.
I'm Liv. I'm a cook here.
And I'm just honored today to be
here with John Jeavons and
to introduce him to you.
If you care anything about what
your food tastes like, if
you've dug a fork into food, you
really care about digging
a fork into the Earth.
And that's my whole connection
to all of this.
You care about not just the
quality of food, but whether
food is going to feed everybody
on this planet,
which is one of the main
questions we have to answer
these days--
enough food, enough nutritious
food for everybody.
When I was assigned to China as
a reporter a few years ago,
for me, the most heartbreaking
thing I saw was in the
countryside to see these dense
concentrations of farmers who
were asked to leave the land
that they had farmed for
generations and put in densely
populated living conditions no
longer close to their
land because
land was that precious.
And the government wanted
to develop it.
And here, I saw people who
knew the art of farming--
and it is indeed an
art, growing food
and growing it well--
who had been through chemical
industrial farming who were
told that some of the land that
they farm was now too
toxic, over-fertilized, and
over-chemicalized for them to
do any more, but who still in
their genes and just one
generation back knew how to
grow food in mainly a
sustainable way.
And to me, I brought
that home with me.
And to me, it's the overriding
question for this age
and for all of us.
So from the time I was an
immigrant that arrived in this
country, I'd heard about
double digging.
I'd heard about biointensive.
And today, for me to meet John
and realize that he is this
complete visionary who isn't
just a farmer, but is thinking
about food for all of us and for
the future of this planet
is indeed an honor.
So please welcome John.
[APPLAUSE]
JOHN JEAVONS: Thank
you, Liv. Take the
lights down on the screen.
They got me lit.
Before we begin, I'd
like to make one
reflection to set the tone.
What Liz said about China in
some way reminded me of it.
In 1995, we had an intern come
and train with us in Northern
California for six months.
And he shared with me that the
cost of farmable soil in
Monterey, Mexico,
was $4 a pound.
Do you realize that gasoline
only costs $50 a pound
currently at the pump?
$50.
Oh, there we go again.
We're going to have
to redo this one.
Do you realize that in Monterey,
Mexico, that
farmable soil, if you go to
purchase it, costs $4 a pound,
where gasoline at the pumps
today costs $0.50 a pound.
So they have their
priorities right.
They realize the preciousness
of the soil.
And they realize that the soil
is worth eight times gasoline.
Wow.
That's really hard to wrap our
minds around, I think.
Even for me, it is, and
I've been working
with this for 41 years.
So now let's go and look at our
presentation for today,
Food for the Future Now.
To know, challenge, and hope.
To feel, relieved
and empowered.
And to do, act where you are.
Creating a new and
better world.
This is going to be the only
thing we need to focus on.
The joy of the process, it's
really a lot of fun.
You can see the happiness
in my daughter's face.
And even manual food-raising,
which is really
skill-intensive, not
work-intensive, is a lot of fun.
The Earth needs our help now.
You probably know
that already.
But this is literally the Earth
that's underneath our
feet needs our help right now.
Let's grow soil.
It's not about farming it.
It's about growing it.
Every time we eat a pound of
food grown with regular
food-raising practices, an
average of 6 pounds in the
United States, 12 pounds in
developing countries, where
90% of the world's people live,
and 18 pounds in China,
where 20% of the world's people
live, and 24 pounds of
farmable soil in California are
lost due to wind and water
erosion because of the types
of practices being used.
In contrast, over here on
the right, you can see
Biointensive Sustainable
Mini-Farming has the capacity
to build, to grow, to create
up to 20 pounds of farmable
soil per pound of food eaten--
not deplete 6 to 24 pounds per
pound of food eaten, but to
build up to 20 pounds of
farmable soil, soil we need to
feed people.
I don't think anyone realizes
the number of people that are
born each day, really.
It's 216,000 people net.
That's births less deaths.
It's like Motel 6, and the
light's on all the time.
This is enough to
repopulate San
Francisco every three days.
Wow.
Costa Rica every 17.
Mexico City, the second largest
city in the world, 3.5
times a year.
And Beijing, China,
8.6 times a year.
What does this mean?
It means--
and this is even more
important than those
population statistics--
it means that 34,000 additional
acres of farmable
soil need to be found or built
daily to feed these people.
It's not happening.
It's probable that organic
farming indirectly results in
the loss of three to five and
a quarter pounds of farmable
soil per pound of food eaten
because of the needs of inputs
in the form of compost, manure,
and organic fertilizer
which are taken from
other soils.
So we may have our perfect
organic farm.
But we're depleting a
soil somewhere else
in order to do it.
We don't need to.
But the pattern we're
using now does.
Organic farming is
a good start.
It's a great start.
It's a major positive step
towards more sustainable
agriculture.
Yet, we need to take
at least three
more major steps forward.
We need to go beyond organic.
The planet is becoming
increasingly urbanized.
Something that's incredible is
India's already 91% urban,
China 90% urban.
That's 40% of the world's
population virtually urbanized.
One of the results of this
urbanization is that we're
losing our farming literacy.
We don't really know
how to farm.
As a result of all these
factors, agriculture, as it
is, population growth, the
loss of our farming skill
base, most of the world's
soils have become
significantly demineralized,
compacted, and contain little
organic matter unless all these
elements have been imported.
This isn't a pretty picture.
Though, I think the art
here is very pretty.
You can make a case that the
entire planet may be
desertified in as little
as 69 years.
I'm 70 years old.
That's in less time than I've
been here on the planet.
| don't know how long
you've been here.
But that's a short time.
What to do?
We need to make farming truly
sustainable on as much of a
closed system basis
as possible.
It is possible.
We need to grow our own organic
matter inputs on the
soil we cultivate and recycle
all the nutrients--
contained in the crops we
grow back into the soil.
The United Nations Food and
Agriculture Organization has
noted that 13 years from
now, in the year 2025--
that's soon--
about 2/3 of the world's people,
5 billion people, will
probably not have sufficient
water available for food
growing to live a life
with reasonable
nutrition if at all.
We don't have to wait for
2025 for that to happen.
We're going to see that
happening in just three years,
the effect of this.
This means a situation of peak
water and peak food.
70% to 80% of all the water used
by people in the world is
utilized in food production.
There is some hope.
We'll get to that soon.
You can also make a case that
as little as 49 years of
farmable soil remains
on the Earth.
This is partly because as the
soil quality is depleted, the
rate of depletion increases
more rapidly.
So we have a situation of
peak farmable soil.
And it's here now.
There's also a major different
kind of peak energy crisis.
The peak energy crisis really
is between these two points
and these two points--
our will, the will to face
these things and make a
positive difference.
And I wouldn't tell you these
things if we couldn't make a
positive difference.
Feed your dreams and your
fears will starve.
So in the future, as you begin
to be overwhelmed by
challenges, and there's a good
chance that we will all have
that feeling some of the time,
feed your dreams. And you'll
find that the dream that you're
envisioning will begin
to manifest.
And the reason that we can dream
these dreams is because
there are realistic solutions.
We need to utilize our
skillful will.
There are psychologists who
have studied the different
forms of will that we have. And
the most important one is
skillful will, the ability to
make and fulfill our choices
with the greatest efficiency
and least effort necessary.
I think Google is dedicated
to this concept.
What we need is a
transformational paradigm
throughout many areas, including
food-raising.
Growing food was actually
the original green.
And it can be again.
In fact, 10,000 years ago--
this is unbelievable if
you really sink into
this and feel it.
This next thing is just totally
unbelievable and wonderful.
10,000 years ago, early Stone
Age farmers raised 100% of
their calories per person with
just 20 hours of labor
annually, growing the
first spelt wheat.
These people were farming
literate.
I often give participants in
our workshop a handicap, a
fivefold handicap.
And I challenge them to learn
how to grow all their food in
100 hours a year during the
following three years.
We really can do it.
We don't believe we can, but
that's where the problem is,
here and here.
In 1911, China grew complete
diets on 3,600 square feet.
And China, Japan, and Korea used
biologically-intensive
farming successfully for four
millennia until the 1950s when
current practices began
to be adopted.
The Chinese used to call their
farmers living libraries.
And if you want to read about
this type of farming, there's
a book out by F.H. King called
Farmers of Forty Centuries.
I recommend you read it.
It's published by Dover Press,
and it's not expensive.
In the Philippines, the
illiterate Hanunoo Stone Age
culture have a 200-crop,
5-year rotation with 40
varieties of rice
grown annually.
So no matter what the climate,
hot, cold, wet, or dry, they
achieve a sufficient quantity
of calories.
They are living libraries too.
There are no agricultural
universities that I know of in
the world that have any kind of
rotation system that's as
sophisticated, or as complex,
and uses so many varieties as
this one does.
And these people don't
know how to read
and don't use computers.
Oh my god.
And it's even worse because they
spend 80% of their table
conversation at meals talking
about farming.
And their children, if they were
in inner city schools,
you'd have to disassociate
yourself from them because
they play farmer.
When other cultures around them
were fading, the Mayan
culture thrived with
neighborhood--
there's documentation
on this--
neighborhood
biologically-intensive
food-raising.
Why did the Mayan culture
eventually dissipate?
No one knows.
There's maybe five or
six possibilities.
But one of them no
one has listed.
They may not have been farming
with biological intensivity in
a sustainable way.
You can deplete your soil really
fast if you don't do it
sustainably.
Biosphere II, where they locked
six people up in a
two-acre greenhouse for two
years, grew complete diets on
about 3,300 square feet with
biologically-intensive practices.
In fact, one of our interns
trained the basis for that
food-raising.
Ecology Action, Grow
Biointensive, registered
trademark, Sustainable
Mini-Farming, feeding the
world one garden at the time.
We began relearning, teaching,
and researching--
relearning, see, because we
didn't know anything, and
we're still learning.
We began relearning, teaching,
and researching
biologically-intensive
food-raising in the Stanford
University Industrial Park over
40 years ago in 1972.
We developed a systems
approach.
Because I'm really interested
in patterns.
You can learn more faster
with patterns.
And the systems approach
enables people to learn
faster, teach more effectively,
and take more
efficient action.
One intern from Latin America
told us that after his first
four weeks in our six-month
intern program that he'd
learned more than he'd learned
in six years in the university
in his country.
He didn't learn more
information.
He learned more of a pattern and
a system which enabled him
to put the data bits and the
information into the most
effective places.
Grow Biointensive is now used
in over 143 countries in
virtually all climates and soils
where food is grown.
It's taught at tours, classes,
three-day and five-day
domestic and international
workshops, two- and six-month
internships, and three-year
apprenticeships.
This year, we have
a new program.
Our two-month internship is
especially for college
students that during their
summers can come and get a
taste of farming and decide if
they want to get into it.
It's exciting.
We've had three times the number
of applicants than we
have positions for.
And it's not just limited
to college students.
We have one person who is
from Uzbekistan who
will be taking it.
And she'll be going back and
teaching people in all the
-istans in the former
Soviet Union.
This information is learned
also from over 250 how-to
books, booklets, and information
sheets, and even
videos on topics such as how to
grow complete nutrition and
soil fertility in the
smallest area.
This is what's motivated
me for over 40 years.
In the 1970s, I wanted to know
what's the smallest area that
you could grow all your food,
all your clothing, all your
money, and all your other
agricultural products from in
an environmentally sound way
and an equitable way.
So that if everyone in the world
used that technique or a
similarly effective technique,
that everyone could live well.
We now know that you can grow
all your seed for next year in
3% additional area.
And we have a booklet out called
"Growing the Seed" that
shows you how to grow all your
seed in the smallest area
while preserving genetic
diversity.
It used to be that in order to
design a diet, you needed to
read our booklet number 31,
"Designing a Complete Grow
Biointensive Sustainable
Mini-Farm." And there's just
lots of pages and
charts in there.
And the result is growing
all your food in
4,000 square feet.
In the United States, it takes
30,000 square feet.
It's not the same food, but all
the nutrients are there.
Well, it takes a lot of time
to fill out these forms and
understand them.
But now we can teach you from
your heart how to make choices
in five minutes, so you can
design your own diet and one
that will produce all the
composts for the diet of the
microbes in the soils in
less than an hour.
So this is the kind of
simplicity that grows out of
the systems approach.
How to Grow More Vegetables Than
You Ever Thought Possible
on Less Land Than You Can
Imagine has increased to and
Fruits, Nuts, Berries, Grains,
and Other Crops.
The title just got longer.
Imagine.
It's in eight languages,
including Braille, and now
going into four more
languages.
The fully revised, updated, and
expanded eighth edition
has just been published.
We're teaching in the field
and on the web.
There are five training sites
in the US, four of them in
California.
Next year, there'll be one in
North Carolina in addition to
the one that's in
Ohio this year.
We have international partner
training sites in Latin
America, Africa, and Asia.
Ecology Action's website has a
self-teaching section where
you can download a 12-page How
to Grow More Vegetables
equivalent for free.
It has eight training videos
that you can download from
YouTube and use for free.
We also sell the DVD.
So you can have all
of it right there.
Our international mail order
service can be found at
bountifulgardens.org.
Our website is
growbiointensive.org.
Our garden supply and education
center can be
located right here in the San
Francisco mid-peninsula Bay
Area in Palo Alto, California.
And you can go online to
commongroundinpaloalto.org.
There's some cards at the back
that you can get more
information about all of
these initiatives.
My site, johnjeavons.info,
includes a special section
that I really encourage you to
look at called "The World of
Hope." It has eight
segments to it.
And I recommend that you read
one a day and absorb the hope
that's contained in it.
Onward, to help meet the world's
challenges, Ecology
Action has developed a proposal
to train a half
million African farmers in six
countries in four and a
quarter years at a cost
of only $9 a person.
In a world that has economic
challenges, this is a great
opportunity to make
a difference.
I don't know if you know, but
there are a billion people in
Africa, and 1/3 of them are
on starvation track.
We want to meet that
challenge.
We're also developing a similar
proposal to train
500,000 Latin American farmers
in all 22 countries.
It's exciting.
We can't wait.
We're working with the US
Department of Agriculture
currently to catalyze four Grow
Biointensive teaching
mini-ag centers and soil test
stations to monitor how the
soil quality improves, stays the
same, or whatever in the
Sudan, where 4 to 7 million
people are at risk for
malnutrition and/or
starvation.
Our international partners,
Samuel Nderitu from G-BIACK in
Kenya, who helps us in so many
ways, will be doing the
initial trainings
there next week.
We've discovered that this
method, Grow Biointensive
Sustainable Mini-Farming, has
the capacity to produce higher
yields and increased income per
unit of area and use as
little as 33% to
12% the water.
We've been down as low
as 3% the water.
Use as little as 50% to 100%
less purchased nutrient and
organic fertilizer form.
And use as little as 6% to 1%
the energy in all forms,
compared with practices normally
used per pound of
food produced.
Grow Biointensive builds soil.
According to a master's thesis
from the University of
California at Berkeley in the
soil science department there,
Grow Biointensive has the
capacity to build soil up to
60 times more rapidly
than in nature.
What does this mean?
Up to six inches of farmable
soil can be built in as little
as 50 years.
Remember earlier I noted that
in as little as 49 years,
there might be no farmable
soil left.
So we might as well begin
now and avoid the rush.
We could be in time.
On the average around the
world and in the US, it
doesn't take 50 years to build
up 6 inches of farmable soil,
the depth of soil you need
in order to grow food.
It takes 3,000 years
to do this.
And in California, because
of the natural geologic
formation, the climate, and
other factors, it takes 12,000
years to build up 6 inches
of farmable soil.
Do you realize that the 3,000
years of farmable soil that
we've built up in the United
States, that we've depleted
75% of it in the
last 250 years?
We depleted 2,250 years'
worth in 250 years.
And the rate at which it's being
depleted is increasing.
We don't have to do that.
With Grow Biointensive higher
yields plus a better
understanding of nutrition from
a farming point of view,
it's possible to grow diets plus
all the compost materials
needed for sustainable soil
fertility on as little as
4,000, 2,500, 1,800, or even
1,000 square feet or less
depending on the diet.
You could even do it
in the yard on your
suburban home lot.
Frightening, the responsibility
is.
It's true that the foods
eaten are different.
But all nourishment for world
standards is met in all of
these small diets.
How does Grow Biointensive
do this?
Deep soil structure
creation for
quadruple nutrient cycling.
Compost for microbe nutrition.
Soil, water retention, and soil
antibiotic development.
Plants don't get sick if you
have enough microbes in the
soil because they have their own
pharmaceutical thing going
on down there to keep
the plants healthy.
And if the plants are healthy,
insects don't come because the
amino acid mix in the plant
tissue is such that the
insects are not interested.
But a sick plant, the amino
acid mix changes.
And the signal goes out to the
insects, and they come for
their feast.
Close plant spacing for improved
plant environment and
water conservation.
Companion planting, putting
plants together that like each
other and stimulate
each other--
like the people you choose for
your parties or your dinners--
for crop enhancement and
pest minimization.
60% growing area in compost and
calorie crops that produce
large amount of compost
materials, plus a significant
quantity of calories,
such as wheat,
oats, corn, and amaranth.
But there are many others.
30% of our growing area in
special root crops-- and in a
moment, you'll see how important
that is, it's very
important--
such as potatoes, garlic, and
leeks that can produce 5 to 20
times the calories per unit
of area per unit of time.
Using easily available seeds.
And using the whole system.
It doesn't work well if only
some of its elements are used.
If you prepare the soil
shallowly and put all the
plants close together,
you stress the soil.
And the system may even
become unsustainable.
The solution to sustainable
agriculture isn't the system.
It's you, and me, and
how we use it.
Taking into account all the
preceding, scarcity can be
transformed into abundance.
The transformation of the
situations of peak water, peak
farming energy, and peak
farmable soil into situations
of more than enough.
We don't need to be facing
the scarcity that
we're looking at globally.
We can be looking at
abundance instead.
In a way, it's not all
that challenging.
You may feel overwhelmed
right now.
But let's go to a quote from
Voltaire in his book Candide,
on the last page.
Candide says, "The whole world
is a garden, and what a
wonderful place it would be if
each one of us just took care
of our part of the Earth,
our garden."
It's not complicated.
It's simple.
It's not someone else who
needs to take the
responsibility.
We can.
And it's a pleasurable
responsibility.
Gandhi, "To forget how to dig
the Earth and tend the soil is
to forget oneself." Grow
Biointensive is
skill-intensive, rather
than labor-intensive.
As you can see here, there's as
many lettuces in the upper
area as in the lower area.
The amount of work, if you
know how to Aikido double
dig-- which actually, you
don't do the work.
Gravity does the work.
The amount of energy it takes
to double dig that in a very
quiet, simple, easy way is the
same amount of energy that it
is to single dig two
of those row areas.
So it's less work.
It's less water.
It's less weeding.
It's less compost. It's less
nutrients in organic
fertilizer form.
It's skill-intensive.
Don't work harder.
Think smarter.
Small is bountiful.
And there truly are economies
of small scale.
Remember how much less water
and nutrient we use?
Those are economies
of small scale.
And we need to become
farming literate.
So what does this mean for
us in our own backyards?
And what does this mean
for our communities?
Assuming intermediate Grow
Biointensive yields, one
mature apple tree can produce
one pound of apples for each
day in the year for three
and a quarter people.
In addition, you can graft 9
additional varieties on the
tree for a total of 10
producing varieties.
Luther Burbank had 30 varieties
of plums grafted on
one plum tree in Santa
Rosa, California.
You can go still see the tree.
It only has 10 varieties on it
now because they didn't want
to keep up with that
complexity.
But wouldn't it be wonderful
to go have that kind of a
choice right at home?
Also assuming intermediate Grow
Biointensive yields, you
can grow one 1-pound loaf of
bread for each week in the
year in just 300 square feet of
wheat, two good-sized bowls
of oatmeal per week in another
300 square feet
using hulless oats.
You can experience that
primordial waves of grain
feeling right where you are.
Now all crops are not equal.
This is really important.
And if you get the new edition
of How to Grow More
Vegetables, the last three
pages also of the compost
chapter describe how all
compost is not equal.
Here, what we're going to see
is we have wheat, which is a
winter grain crop.
And the calories produced per
month set our index of one
unit of productivity.
If instead we use flour corn,
which is a summer seed crop,
we have five times the
productivity and
calories per month.
And if instead we use potatoes,
a 65-day maturing
variety, we get nineteen times
the calories per month per
unit of area.
Powerful.
If you read the material on
compost, you'll find that
instead of just having a bucket
of compost that you
dump into an area where you're
growing, that bucket of
compost can be one unit of
compost power, two units of
compost power, and up to eight
units of compost power.
This is what 41 years of
research, teaching, and, most
important, learning by Ecology
Action is making possible for
everyone in the world
on a simple basis.
But the final question really
is, what kind of future do you
want to create?
Because it's really
up to each of us.
There's applications here for
localization of food growing,
including public toolbraries
of small-scale food-raising
and cleaning tools.
You could thresh your grain
right at your local library.
Seed exchanges with growing
collection and
preservation classes.
Demonstration orchards with a
wide spectrum of heritage
fruit and nut trees.
There's hundreds of varieties
to choose from.
Mini-ag centers for learning,
training, and growing food.
More local farms for foods,
including green belts and
business parklands.
Smaller, more income productive
microforms growing
specialty crops.
Do you realize that the average
income for the average
US farmer is about $6,700 for
a half million dollars of
capital investment?
It's about a 2% return
on investment.
And the farmer has to work, he
or she has to work, to get the
other $33,300 a year needed to
live on at an off the farm,
non-farm job.
With small-scale, sustainable,
biologically-intensive
farming, you can make up to
$50,000 and more on a quarter
of an acre net.
There was a man who did this in
Berkeley, California already.
And there are other people
beginning to do it.
One of the exciting things is
more and more women are
getting into farming.
Another thing that we can
include in our localization
possibilities are two-acre,
complete diet,
community-supported agriculture
mini-farms. This
is where a family farm could
grow enough food for complete
diets for 20 people and
make $40,000 a year.
Most important, grow a
community attitude.
We must be the change that we
wish to see in the world.
And last but not least,
we can grow new
kinds of living contexts.
A land trust sustainable
mini-farming community is
where you have three 33-family
neighborhoods
in a 130-acre area.
And each family has a half-acre
farm in which they
can grow all the food for their
three- to four-person
family and grow $40,000
a year or more.
Now this quote from Abraham
Lincoln was given in 1857.
And how did this man know?
He was busy and occupied with
a few other topics.
"Before long, the most valuable
of all arts will be
that of deriving a comfortable
subsistence from the smallest
area of land." It's going to be
the only game in town for
most of the world's people and
already is for many of them.
Working together, we can
build a better future.
To keep it simple, what's one
tiny thing that each of us can
do today to create
a better world?
It truly only takes a smile
exchanged with another person
to cause a ripple effect that
will change the world.
And we can begin today.
We don't have to wait.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
LIV: Thank you so much.
JOHN JEAVONS: You're welcome.
LIV: So I'm feeling guilty for
the bags of compost that I
bought and the irrigation
system that I have.
JOHN JEAVONS: We all have
to start somewhere.
LIV: We do.
So let's go straight
to what you said.
What should Google do?
We just feed people all
three meals every day.
JOHN JEAVONS: I think it would
be wonderful if Google could
be one of the pace setters
for the world.
I think they could have a green
belt farm right out in
this area, somewhere
not too far away.
They could support the new
type of farmer who's more
efficient, using fewer
resources, and produce all the
food that you need to feed
everyone here, the 15,000 to
20,000 people that you feed
daily, which is incredible.
But think of the kind of
jobs that you can make.
And a lot of these can be really
small farms that are
supporting the re-education of
our population in farming.
Most of the world's really
illiterate in farming.
And it's pretty scary.
If this whole room were a
football field, and there were
625 people in it, and one person
in the middle had a
green cap on, and a green hat,
and green pants, that's the
token farmer.
That's the person who is raising
the food for himself
and the other 624 people.
And that person generally knows
how to grow a few crops.
And the soil that he's growing
it from, or she's growing it
from, is being depleted
really rapidly.
But we need to not discount
these farmers.
They really love farming,
and they care about us.
And they want to feed us.
And they're going bankrupt.
Can you imagine?
Just to feed us.
And so we need to give
them some help
with some new patterns.
And I think Google is uniquely
in a position to consider, in
a small way, having
a pilot for that.
LIV: So tell me, let's
get in depth.
What does that look like?
How big should the
green belt be?
Where do we gather the literate
farmers that we want?
And how big is each unit
for each farm family?
JOHN JEAVONS: Well, that's
a good question.
First of all, we have to
not only grow soil.
We're going to have
to grow farmers.
And that takes some time, and
everybody isn't going to be
perfect the first time out.
Many people in the world get
out of farming because it
depends on weather.
It depends on soil and the
fluctuation of markets.
But if you were to grow
enough farmers
to feed all of Google--
we're talking about thousands
of farmers--
how about starting
with 5 or 10?
LIV: OK, all right.
Let's do that.
JOHN JEAVONS: And then if the
pattern works, and the farmers
are happy, and they're making
more money than they've been
making otherwise, I don't think
you're going to have to
do a whole lot to get
it to spread.
LIV: OK, so five farm families,
two acres each?
Is that what I was getting?
JOHN JEAVONS: It depends
on which of the
patterns you choose.
You can choose one that's
growing complete diets.
growing mainly high-end
vegetables, which we all
in California like
to eat a lot of.
You can have others that
are growing seeds.
And if you grow seeds and those
farmers become their own
seed company, you can make a
lot of money with seeds.
So I would suggest at least
those three types of
approaches, the ones that are
complete diet, the ones that
are mainly high-end vegetables,
and another that's
growing seeds.
LIV: And the soil growing, we
can get the first generation
going in six months?
JOHN JEAVONS: Well, when we
began at the Stanford
University Industrial Park,
all the top soil had been
scraped off of the area that
was donated to us.
And all of the subsoil had
been scraped off in the
construction process.
So we were growing our crops
in a mollisol clay that
normally takes at least 500
years in nature to make one
inch of farmable soil out of.
And we got fairly good results
to begin with.
But you get better results
over time.
One thing that I want everyone
to understand is to build up a
soil in a temperate zone and to
have a good soil, you need
4% to 6% organic matter
in the soil.
Most of the world's soils are
only 1% organic matter.
And you can only, in a stable
way, build up a soil in
organic matter 1/20
of 1% a year.
So to build up from 1% organic
matter soil to 4%, the minimum
to have a really good
soil, it's going
to take us 60 years.
So it involves a responsibility,
a commitment,
and a relationship.
We know how difficult
relationships are.
But this one's with the soil
and with the planet.
And to be a farmer of the
future, what we're going to
have to do-- this is going
to be really hard because
nobody's going to
want to do it.
I promise you.
You have to leave half of your
farmable soil in wild because
what we're growing is we're
growing a planet.
We're not growing food.
We're growing soil.
And we're not growing
just soil.
We need to grow ecosystems.
And if we take all the
farmable soil and we grow food
with it, the natural cycles of
plants and animals are
just going to tank.
LIV: Is there a way for me to
tell my gophers to stay on the
wild side and not come
into my garden?
JOHN JEAVONS: There are, but we
can't talk about that here.
LIV: OK.
Yes, please, questions?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Could you speak to whether--
there's a lot of other
systems out there.
There's no-till.
There's food forest. There's
the biodynamics people,
biochart enthusiasts, the
permaculture folks, the soil
food web, creating natural
farming, IMOs.
There's all these alternative
agriculture systems out there.
Could you speak to your
organization's relation to them?
Do you think you're
an alternative?
Or you incorporate ideas
from them all?
Or how does that work?
JOHN JEAVONS: OK, I think the
first thing I'd like to
describe is that the bottom
line is the soil.
And I have evaluated what's
happening to soils in other
systems. And generally,
the soil's being
depleted fairly rapidly.
So I don't need to specify
which systems. I'd
just as soon not.
Because the goal here isn't
for how so much that we're
different, or whether
we're better or
less good, or whatever.
The real goal here is how
do we build the soil.
And so if each one of
us, whether we're
permaculturalists, whether
we're biodynamic, whether
we're Fukuoka culture, which
there's a tremendous amount to
be said for, the important
thing is what is it
doing to the soil?
So our teaching units, which are
a minimum of 4,000 square
feet of plantable surface,
because you can easily do a
complete diet for yourself and
for the microbes, they're not
only called mini-ag centers.
They're also called soil
test stations.
And they're not going to test
your soil or my soil.
They're going to monitor their
own soil so that we can see.
Is it getting better?
Is it getting worse?
Is it staying the same?
And we have a new program
that we're
developing that's actually--
already, we have a very,
very small grant--
in Africa, in Kenya, where
we're doing it.
But we're going to begin to
list key points around the
world where the soil's
been tested.
And we're going to say the
altitude, the longitude, the
soil type, and the climate for
each one of these nodes.
And then we're going to show
online these 24 soil
nutrients, and relationships,
and aspects, how they were
tested out, what they were
missing, what was done to
improve them.
And then we're going to
show yield levels for
five years or more.
So that you won't need, I won't
need Ecology Action.
What you do is you go online,
and you'll educate yourself
about what someone in a
similar situation did.
So it becomes a big chat room in
a way even though it won't
have that capacity.
Does that answer
your question?
AUDIENCE: Pretty much.
Thank you.
JOHN JEAVONS: OK.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Can you talk a little bit about
sustainable ways to
harvest and utilize water?
JOHN JEAVONS: OK, sustainable
water use?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JOHN JEAVONS: Sure,
I'd be glad to.
First of all, if you want to
reduce your water consumption
per unit of calorie produced,
a really good
crop to grow is potatoes.
It produces a lot of calories
per unit of
water per unit of time.
Another crop that's fairly
efficient is carrots.
I was surprised.
I thought, carrots
are succulent.
They're crunchy.
But they're really
water efficient.
There are a number of crops in
the world in the grain seed
area that are called C4 crops.
They have a special
genetic pathway.
And this enables them to produce
more calories and more
carbon with less water.
But I'll give you an idea of
what this method that we're
using and learning about does.
In the Stanford Industrial Park,
when we began in 1972 in
Santa Clara County, where you
are right now, they were using
20 gallons of water for 100
square feet per day in
agriculture.
When we began, we were too.
After five years, we were down
to 10 gallons of water per 100
square feet per day.
And after six, we were down
to 8 gallons of water.
But the yields that we
were getting were two
to five times higher.
So really, we would end up
using, to make a long story
short, 1/8 the water per pound
of vegetable produced.
Now how do we do this?
And that's what you're asking.
First of all, we have
a new booklet out.
It's called booklet 35.
It's name is "Growing More Food
with Less Water." So I'll
tell you the three ways that
this method enables you to use
so much less water.
What it means is that those
people, the 5 billion people
who don't have enough water very
soon to grow their food,
could have enough water
to grow their food.
The first way is that if you
build up the organic matter in
your soil, you can reduce the
amount of water you need to
grow food by as much as 75%.
That's huge.
Secondly, if you put all the
plants close together that the
deep soil preparation allows
you to do, you get a
mini-climate.
And it shades the ground.
And you can reduce the amount
of water you need by an
additional up to 50% less.
Now we were already
from 75% down.
So we're at 25% of the water
being used because of the
organic matter.
So now we can get it down to
12 and 1/2% the water being
used by the shading of the
ground with the mini-climate.
And last, but not least--
and this one is just a
mind blower to me--
but I always thought plants
drank water in order to stand
up and get water
turgor, right?
Well, that's not untrue.
But the main reason they drink
water is to get food.
And if there's enough nutrients
in your soil, when
they drink the water, one gulp,
and they get enough food
for a long time.
And they don't have to drink
more water right away.
So you can then reduce by as
much as an additional 75% the
amount of water you need.
So you can take it down.
We were at 12 and 1/2%.
You can take it down to as
little as 3% of the water.
And we reached that in the
Stanford Industrial Park with
a crop that you'll laugh
at, zucchini.
So that's how we do it.
LIV: So you're actually
answering one of the questions
I wanted to ask you most, which
is what does this food
taste like.
And when you're telling me it's
nutrient dense, I know it
tastes great and it's
really good for you.
The two are the same.
JOHN JEAVONS: Yeah, we grow tree
collards in our garden.
They are indigenous to Africa
and/or the Gurney Islands just
off of England.
And they're green milk.
And not only do they taste good,
but one of the exciting
things you may not realize is if
this room were all growing
alfalfa, and we fed it to a
cow, and you drank all the
milk from that, the alfalfa that
went through the cow, you
drank the milk that it produced,
and instead, you had
tree collards planted in this
same area, you'd get four
times the protein and eight
times the calcium from the
tree collards.
And it's been tested with
Mexican schoolchildren.
And it's been found to work as
well as milk or even a little
bit better.
So there's marvelous
possibilities.
The one that I like the best in
nutrition that just makes
me smile is parsley.
Now in India, there's 200
million children who have
brain damage and eye sight
damage because they didn't get
enough Vitamin A and iron during
their early life, the
first six years.
In 25 square feet, a five by
five square foot plot, they
can grow with parsley all the
missing Vitamin A and iron
that they didn't get.
And so they could take care
of their own issue, which
shouldn't be their issue.
But they could intervene.
And one of the things we found
in Mexico is that often, the
adults won't do manual
food-raising.
So the kids do it.
And the kids eventually
teach the parents
how to get into it.
It's a mind blower.
This happened in the first
project in Mexico at Vicente
Guerrero, 200 miles southeast
of Mexico City.
Two Quakers from Palo Alto, Eric
and Kaki, went in for two
years to teach biointensive.
And no one would do it.
So the kids did.
And I have photographs of
them with pick axes
prepping the beds.
And it worked.
So after the first year, the
families had family councils.
And they all said, it works.
And the father said, mamasita,
you do it.
So the next year, the children
and the mothers did it.
And they continued
to be successful.
And Kaki and Eric were supposed
to leave at the end
of the second year.
But they realized it
wouldn't continue.
There wasn't enough
momentum yet.
So they stayed a third year.
And they picked out
the best mothers.
And they taught them to be
managers of the program.
And it continued.
So you'd be surprised
about kid power.
And people tell us in Africa
that people with AIDS won't do
this because it's manual, and
they don't have enough energy.
Well, let me tell
you, they do it.
They love doing it.
It gets them more food, and it
stabilizes, in many cases,
their AIDS.
It doesn't cure them, but
it alleviates it.
And so it's more like we, from
developed countries, can't
imagine somebody doing manual
gardening, especially if
you've got AIDS.
And we have a photo of
a blind person in
India double digging.
Can you imagine?
You can't get people with sight
to double dig sometimes.
So it gets more and more fun
as you learn more and more.
AUDIENCE: I've just been
beginning to brainstorm as to
how to maybe pull this off.
If you have a customer like
Google that needs 20,000
people a day fed, you've got all
these people like us that
have backyards.
There's even a book
you mentioned,
The Apartment Farmer.
There's people here from the
permaculture group, Chris
Burley, Hayes Valley Farm.
All these folks could be growing
this kind of stuff.
Maybe we could take a boot camp
course in biointensive,
so we could get up to speed
real quick and get the
hundreds of farmers
that we'd need.
So now you have people
that could have
all this spare income.
You could maybe get it down to
a few hours, like you say, a
day or a month in terms
of tending the farm.
So you do something before
you go to work.
Come back, put a little
more water on it.
Then on the weekends, you go
down to the farmer's market.
And Liv is there picking up
stuff for the Google kitchens
or something like that.
The pieces are there if
we can just figure out
how to put it together.
JOHN JEAVONS: And Cliff, I don't
know because the mic
didn't seem to be picking
it up fully.
So I'll try to paraphrase.
And you can correct me
if I miss something.
Cliff is suggesting that maybe
having a boot camp for Grow
Biointensive Sustainable
Mini-Farming for people
connected with Google could
enable them in window boxes
using the techniques in the two
editions of The Apartment
Farmer by Duane Newcomb and
other techniques in other good
books to do it in window
boxes, or barrels, and
containers.
Also, he indicated, as he and
I have talked about, it's
possible to grow all the
vegetables for one person for
all year in this kind
of climate in 200
square feet or less.
And it actually would probably
take you something like 30
minutes a day.
And maybe people could
do it before work.
Actually, it's an invigorating
thing after work.
But I'll have to let people
experience that themselves.
It's a big mental
jump to make.
I feel more invigorated after
double digging than before.
And if I don't double dig
every three days, I feel
withdrawal.
So that may not be
true for you.
Then Cliff suggested that the
food from these 100 square
foot, 200 square foot gardens,
window box, and barrel
gardens, some of it could be
then given to the food bank,
or the farmer's market, or even
the restaurants of the
wonderful cafes here
at Google.
It really is, in the future,
going to take all of us to
make the difference
in the world.
That's why we have
the self-teaching
section of our website.
And even if there weren't the
global challenges that there
are-- and there really are--
it's not just a story.
It's there.
But even if those things weren't
there, we'd be doing
it because it's a lot of fun.
And it's good exercise.
Your food's going
to be fresher.
It's not going to have
pesticides in it.
And you're going to
be building soil.
Can you imagine?
It's going to be as if you
have geological power.
Why not?
LIV: Thank you so much.
JOHN JEAVONS: You're welcome.
[APPLAUSE]